bonsoir et merci d'être en direct avec
nous ce soir sur arte france les pro et
anti armes et au soudan s'opposer dans
la rue depuis quelques temps avant donc
ce coup d'état militaire lundi ce qu'on
a une idée du soutien de la population
dont paix dont bénéficient ces
militaires à aujourd'hui
oui en fait c'est qu'il convient de
souligner ce que le coup d'état a
lui-même étaient rampants le coup d'état
rampant dans la mesure où au sein du
conseil des souverainetés mise en place
depuis 2009 il y avait des conflits donc
il y avait des tensions entre justement
les militaires les dirigeants militaires
et des dirigeants civils en que tension
sur le partage du pouvoir
ce qu'il convient de souliers exactement
c'est que
des lieux quand on des soutiens parce
que l'armée palau bien de la démocratie
clientèle est à dire comme elle fait
partie du conseil décide vérité elle a
apporté certains opposants au sein du
gouvernement et elle a des soutiens elle
a également des soutiens et ce thème
notamment l'egypte et qui soutient en
fait née des généraux donc ce qu'on a
assisté aujourd'hui c'est tout
simplement le ras le bol d'une
population qui n'a plus peur et elle a
vécu trente années de dictature zuma
déchi elle a pris ses responsabilités un
an men en une révolution en 2019
pour prendre en main sa destinée ce coup
d'état finlandais de rendre tout à la
dictature
lorsque nos pays n'a donc plus
d'institutions la population s'érige en
compte le pouvoir avec la volonté de
redonner sens à l'état donc il ya les
partis qui s'affrontent les dirigeants
militaires et des dirigeants civils et
d'aidé aux côtés et à des alliés vous
voulez l'évoquer c'est en août 2019
qu'ont été mises en place des autorités
militaro civil elle était donc chargé de
mener cette transition vers un pouvoir
entièrement civil après le renversement
quatre mois plus tôt du président béchir
vous évoquez des tensions ces derniers
temps concernant le partage du pouvoir
sur quels points très précisément est-ce
que militaire et viel n'arrivaient pas à
se mettre d'accord
ce qui arrive aujourd'hui
ce n'est que l'aboutissement désistement
des tensions que j'ai et un taux évoquée
il convient de souligner que en
septembre dernier déjà il ya eu une
tentative de coup d'état qui a avorté
les militants dénoncent la gestion des
civils mais je pense que
il faut également souligner que les
militaires ont peur d'une chose à dire
c'est que la transition les amène vers
l'inconnu ils redoutent l aboutissement
d'un processus qu'ils enverraient
l'armée dans les casernes
cette du fond du contrôle de leurs cases
elle ils constituent la colonne
vertébrale du régime mais ils veulent
désormais directement est très impliqué
dans la gestion de l'état ces deux
logiciels nario je dirais l'application
du scénario à la perfection de ce qui
s'est passé au mali avec le colonel
assimile guetta qui après avoir mené un
coup d'état et la mise en place d'un
conseil de transition qui allait aboutir
à des élections libres comme c'est le
cas prévu au soudan il a mis fin à cette
période de transition
aujourd'hui le président de la
république fait un chef de l'état je
pense que au soudan c'est en quelque
sorte le même scénario qui se met en
place nous voulons un régime civil ils
n'accepteront pas cette fois le partage
avec les militaires c'est le message des
manifestants aujourd'hui c'est ce que
dit aussi une ministre il n'y aura pas
de négociation avec les militaires
commencent que vous voyez l'évolution de
la situation au soudan c'est c'est tout
prochains jours
c'est une situation assez complexe elle
est assez complexe parce que il ya des
influences externes aujourd'hui j'étais
encore parlé du soutien de l'egypte mais
il faut souligner que ce soutien de
l'egypte c'est aussi le désaveu des
états unis qui avaient
fait un pari sur de cette transition
démocratique à travers des élections
libres et il faut aussi dire que
aujourd'hui les états unis vont donc
faire face à l'influencé de la chine qui
fait sa percée dans cette partie de
l'afrique mais aussi la russie parce que
vous faites là réussi à parler à travers
j'ai tiré son communiqué elle a parlé de
si on arrive à cette situation c'est le
résultat d'une politique raquer une
politique et ne prend pas en compte les
aspirations des populations à côté de
l'un des nations vous avons aussi les
pays du golfe et la turquie ce qui fait
ce qui me fait dire que on s'attendrait
à ce que la communauté internationale
soit un peu plus ferme et vous avez
entendu au fait les mots du secrétaire
général des nations unies il a tout
simplement demandé à ce que les
militaires aient une certaine retenue
mais il n'a pas dénoncé je dirais cette
inclusion directe de l'armée dans la
gestion du pays c'est parce les parties
je dirais à les partis présents sont un
peu plus c'est un peu plus difficile
vous avez d'un côté le monde occidental
et de l'autre côté fin du bloc de l'est
c'est donc cela s'annonce est un peu
plus complexe du point de vue des
solutions
aujourd'hui on se rend compte que même
les sanctions
n'attire plus les sanctions fait ils ne
font pas avec une et l'armée parce que
les états unis ont imposé en fait
homosexuel est ainsi que la banque
mondiale
mais cela ne fait pas plier les
militaires donc les prochains jours
vraiment ça vire ne sont pas de bonnes
ou but et on les fait que la retenue
demandez pas le secrétaire des nations
unies pour que l'armée va l'observer et
que
il va falloir pour décidemment pourquoi
pas essayer de donner une nouvelle
orientation à ce que les militaires
veulent faire de l'état soudanais
aujourd'hui c'est à dire en termes de
démocratie merci beaucoup d'avoir
répondu à notre invitation les au congo
je rappelle que cette politologue
spécialiste des relations
internationales